super bowl weekend always a major draw
for our city sportsbooks packed and this
year pools are open thanks to some
warmer weather a lot of people saying
the end of the mask mandate is a reason
for big business sasha loftis is live
downtown with a look at all the
excitement sasha
yes so much excitement denise and brian
you can see down here on fremont street
it is packed everyone heading out here
for super bowl weekend now most people
we spoke with say they're just happy to
be here in the city others came here to
las vegas because they say they can now
ditch the masks
it's that time again to celebrate the
super bowl in las vegas it's
unbelievable it's electric the big game
always brings big crowds to our city but
this year fans say they're excited to
cheer for their team without a mask for
the first time since 2020. it's pretty
good that they took the protocol for the
mass we're just all ready to go out have
fun here
rex byers is the risk manager at
westgate sportsbook he says this
particular weekend always has a good
turnout but he believes this recent
change will just add to the atmosphere
i'm sure it'll be a lot bigger than what
it would have been had we slept the mass
buyers added that some of his vip guests
called and asked for sunday's spot after
governor sisselak lifted our state's
mandate on thursday literally the same
within a couple hours we had multiple
vips call back and say we changed our
mind we want to come
whether you're rooting for the rams or
counting on cincinnati we think the
bengal is
it looks like southern nevada will be
the spot to celebrate the biggest day in
professional football it's going to be a
great game so looking forward to it
now we've already seen some big bets at
sports sports books rather here in town
rex tells me that at the west gate they
had a bet for 380 thousand dollars for
the super bowl he also says most people
are putting their money on the bengals
reporting live downtown tonight sasha
loftis live local now